my guest tonight is a very talented
comedian and actor who's been
on superstore black monday and in i feel
pretty
uh he is the co-host of a brand new
podcast from team coco called
dads the podcast please welcome our good
friend
hilarious rory scoville rory old pal how
are you
i am so good i am doing
so great really mentally affected or
physically affected by the current state
of the world
i am terrific i've been doing a lot of
zoom interviews
with a lot of people uh your setting
looks the shittiest i'm going to say
that right now
and that's what i was going for there's
a lot of people out there
there's look here's who you've had as
guests conan
liars they want to decorate back here
they're like oh things are great they
they're live it's like instagram what
people are doing on instagram
not me i didn't even put that there for
anyone who can read it
uh you can barely read it i love that
even your sign
promoting your new show robbie on comedy
central
is um impossible to read i didn't put
that there i would never take
credit for that all right well listen
we've got a lot to talk about you rascal
you
uh i was thinking about your life you're
a road comic you're constantly
on the go you're you're always away from
your daughter it must be so nice for you
to be spending time with her
it is um i my wife probably
wishes i could get back out on the road
uh right about now but
yeah with my daughter we're playing
games non-stop
and uh yeah we're you know when you're
gone
you you go on the road you come back
that's what the relationship is to
actually be home
is a whole new is a whole new type of
relationship and it's
great it's the best oh there she is hi
hi elliot
you see conan say hi conan hi you look
pretty elliot
thanks this is mine who told you you
could borrow that
stole that from you that's terrible
[Music]
hide and go seek i am talking to conan
but
i i why don't you hide and then i will
come and
get you uh are you really gonna
find me or are you just gonna tickle me
into a tickle fest well i'll do both if
i find you you are getting tickled
yeah you better get out of here get your
jet
so she's gonna go oh i didn't want
america to see that i talk to her like
that
uh is she going to uh she's going to
hide now and then
you're going to go hide and go seek is
one of the best games these kids
they don't know how long it takes to be
found
and if they commit to the hiding place
it's a good hour
two hours of just catching up on some
golf you know what i mean
well i don't think that's a so wait you
just are gonna let her
hide somewhere in the house for up to
two three hours
yeah your adrenaline is pumping the
whole time my adrenaline's pumping
because i'm getting some stuff
done i'm watching tv and you know
okay yeah that sounds uh and
one time she came out she was hiding and
she came out and i was having
ice cream and that was very traumatizing
for her for her
not for you never the best for me
all right well i uh i i you should
go and why are you drinking out of a jar
vodka in a jar
starting a new company it's called vodka
in a jar
nothing says issues like vodka and sugar
i think you're going to make a lot of
money let's talk about this tour that
you went on okay
yes can i talk about that this is uh
you did a tour uh and i get some credit
here i think
your favorite band is tool that's right
and you did you announced it to our
comedians following
tool on tour the tour
and this was just a tour where you
followed your favorite band tool
and watched them and you went to
whatever city they were in and did
comedy there
totally self-serving yes yes that's 100
true and we announced that tour on your
show and be
and you do you get more than just a
little bit of credit you get a ton of
credit because when i came on the show
and i announced the tour uh the guitars
for the band adam jones
saw that interview and he reached out
and he gave us uh full access
to like go backstage backstage passes at
all the shows
floor seats at all the shows hanging out
we had dinner he came to see some
stand-up shows
so basically was you can sing you used
me
you used me yes to get close to your
favorite band
that's exactly right for what like two
months
while your lovely cute daughter we just
met
was it home alone uh well she might have
been alone but she was hiding
she was hiding for two straight months
probably set some kind of a record
you sound like a a pathologically
terrible dad
um and now you have a podcast called
dads
and it's uh it's on my podcast network
and
you're hosting and this is a podcast
where
uh it's not just a podcast for dads
you're talking about a lot of different
issues
involving fatherhood is that correct
that is correct
uh myself and ruthie wyatt who you know
we co-host the show together and we have
on different guests
like yourself uh today is the first
episode that drops and
uh for everyone who listens conan made
us
have him on he said if you want this
thing to work you got to have the hot
stuff right up front
yeah so he was our first episode and
yeah we talk about
being a dad we talk about having a dad
it's not just for
dads though we also have non-dads on the
show that we interview to get
perspectives about parenting and their
relationships with their dads and
or stepdads or yeah i had a really good
time
talking to you and like i said i did
think it was important
when you launch a podcast you have to
have the hot stuff
that's what i said um and that is
available
uh for everybody wherever you get your
podcast you can check out our interview
with conan
right now and then once a week we'll be
releasing a new
episode we have so many coming up john
leguizamo david cross sabrina jalisce
vanessa ragland the list goes on and on
no it says andrew richter
we call him andy not me he makes me call
him andrew
sir andrew richter sir
you have to call him sir andrew richter
wow yeah i asked i was like is that
don't you have to be knighted but he
said that is technically his first name
andrew is his middle name so
now i want to point something out to you
rory for most of this interview you've
been looking sort of slightly away from
me
and i think probably because of um where
your
camera is or something yeah but i'm
telling you that it makes you look
untrustworthy
i most of the interview you've been
going i really
enjoy working with you conan and it's
it's that
it's that weird i'm just reading the cue
cards
of the person you hired to come over
here you think i want to say hot stuff
i was told i had to say that or the
interview no cue card
there's no cue cards i'm over here
that's not even and just for the
listeners that's a
that's not a real guitar that's a green
screen behind him his basement is worse
than mine
you're not looking at me why are you not
looking at me the zoom thing is so hard
to figure out
everyone else but then i'm looking up
here i'm right here
everyone else is able to do where you
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is you the whole interview i uh i
want to tell you something conan uh and
i mean this from the bottom of my heart
what is that what is that what is that
well the
i have the screen over here of you so
i'm trying to see
you but i i should be looking at the
camera
that's up here so then i can only sort
of see look
everyone watching this right now they
all know the zoom deal if you don't know
the zoom deal by now what's going on you
know the zoom deal
you're over here i gotta look here it's
it's not right it's not right
okay now listen to me we have a lot to
talk about and i'm glad to finally see
your eyes
it's nice you're a handsome fellow
you're a good-looking guy
you mean that cause i have not had a
haircut in about five months
oh really because i'm getting my hair
cut constantly
you look good you really do look good
you know you know i guess i have to say
that without even looking over to see if
i truly believe it because i have to
keep my eyes
on this camera
here's me seeing if i think uh yeah you
look
i like it you're like no you look good
for a guy that's uh trapped in shittiest
basement i've seen in a while
you are a busy busy man you got a comedy
central
uh series uh it's a digital series and
it's called
robbie why don't you tell us a little
bit about robbie
so robbie is the main character
when you talk about like this no one
gets interested right the main character
and he likes basketball he likes
coaching
it uh-huh so he's a basketball coach
he's a church league basketball coach
he's
very uh delusional about his talent and
value
and he wants to take over his dad beau
bridges
he wants to take over his dad's job as
the high school
basketball coach and the series is
really about relationships and robbie
learning that maybe it's time to grow up
and also how do we do that if we're in
our 30s
i'm 40 now and i still don't know that
no i
i mean i made this sign and i'm only now
realizing
based on you seeing it that it's not
even adequate you could say
look i lost some space here and i had to
do letter on num
words on top of words no no that is a
cry for help if ever i've seen one
you know i hear you describe
robbie as this deluded man child
uh living out his fantasies and it's
hard for me not to think
robbie rory do you know what i mean i
wrote from a very real place if that's
what you're
alluding to robbie's not so different
from me
robbie's not so different from america
you know what i mean their show is about
facing some
hard truths in order to grow in the
right direction and i believe that's
kind of where we're at you know what i
mean
okay a little bit of this vodka real
quick i didn't think i was gonna get so
deep out of the game
vodka jar your other uh experiment donna
you have a pretty strong accent in the
show your character
now i know you're from the south yes um
and when i first met you i think the
first time you did stand up on my show i
swear to god
i don't remember what year that was i
think it was 2012 i'm
i'm pretty good with years i'm pretty
sure it was 2012. you came on the show
as a stand-up you had a pretty strong
southern accent
i hate to um put you on the spot but
here's a clip of you in 2012 on my show
and um you sound like gomer pyle let's
take a look
it starts tonight we put a new occupy
movement together
we go down to lunchables and we yell at
the buildings y'all are the worst kind
of crackers
because that that's where they yell at
all the protests you know
explain that explain why your accent was
so okay no one's
no you don't know what the people at
home are doing
they're probably clapping right
i have a monitor here on everyone in
america no no
the ultimate zoom you're on the ultimate
zoom right i have a zoom of everyone in
america it shows 360 million little
faces and
no not one person clapping yeah
were you faking that accent that you're
putting a little english on the ball
i do that yeah yeah it's fun to do that
because then it leaves people
uh guessing is this guy really southern
sometimes i do a german guy sometimes i
just do my own voice and then people
they don't know which one is which one
is which and honestly i get so deep into
these characters as a professional
actor as i'm often described and because
of that i
sometimes i stay in those spaces i i
really don't know what my real voice is
anymore either so
yeah well um and that could be a little
bit of the vodka also
yeah a little bit of the vodka and a
little bit of the looking away you don't
know
stop doing it you can't relate to people
there's people out there doing bedtime
stories online to help
you know put people to sleep at night
you're doing something similar is that
correct
yeah well yeah early on you know there
are a lot of people that were trying to
help parents out
and say hey let me read your kid for a
little bit or at night or
whatever i'll read a book and uh i
thought you know that's not
that that's great but you know who's
reading stories to these
adults to help them get to to sleep at
night and
so uh i'd like to read a little bit of
one here for you now
kind of see if you don't mind hyping it
on the show this kind of good
this is good press for me great okay
this is uh rory scoville
uh this is available i guess is going to
be available
uh reading bedtime stories uh to
absolute ones
so this is just the start of chapter
three okay
um by now it was very clear to the both
of them that it was only a matter of
time so they would be thrusting their
bodies
aggressively into one another they
couldn't wait for the night to start and
the day to end
so that they could dip into a little bit
of the wine and perhaps
each other he saw her eyes from across
the room and
she saw his and she he noticed as she
sexually walked across the room that it
was time to get handsy
and have a little bit of fun i don't
think you should be reading this to kids
what book is this i don't read it to
kids this is for adults this is for
their parents
oh yeah what's the book this is one of
my own i've been working on it's called
the devil's christmas
it's uh you know that's just the start
of chapter three so you can imagine that
i get
i i cut to the chase pretty quick i get
those first two chapters out of the way
who are they what's their relationship
and i
right get them in the cabin together
very quickly they're in a cabin okay
well it's snowed outside they're trapped
there they don't have their clothes or
their luggage
don't imagine how that would have
happened well if you lose your luggage
you lose your clothes
right you got me there you know um
stop looking off to the side look at me
look at me right here
does this look like i'm looking at you
yes right now okay
yes don't don't move your eyes what
color is my shirt
your shirt is blue ah maybe you are
maybe you are right i wasn't i don't i'm
not like you i'm an honest
person you didn't everything you've said
so far is some
is a sham or a lie you didn't write that
book you're not on chat
i don't have a podcast for a show i just
wanted to be on here
i don't know how to get on tv fake it
till you make it yeah
clearly this meant a lot to you and you
chose the prime location
um uh by the way how long where is your
daughter has been
missing a long time is she over oh yeah
no i gotta go look for her
i like to use uh
[Music]
this is how she knows i'm coming if i
find you i'm gonna
eat you
jesus no
rory no that's not good that's just
that's
hiding for that long it's like you got
to get the adrenaline going again she
probably fell asleep
in a closet or something
that's horrific that was horrifying it's
11 o'clock at night what a terrible
thing to do
yeah she shouldn't be up it's kind of
her fault i hope she hid in her bed
um all right i'm gonna get make sure i
get these uh these plugs out you know
what i'm saying that's what we call them
in the biz you know what a plug is
that's why i plug what you're up to all
right all right
all episodes of robbie are current look
at me that's it just stay right there
this is me the whole interview yeah you
should have done that the whole time and
had no expression all episodes of robbie
are currently available on comedy
central's youtube channel
yeah and the first the first episode of
dad's the podcast with team coco was
released today
and uh this is you and i having a
conversation and it was a lot of fun
and you really uh you're you're very
insightful you're also a very funny man
new episodes are available every
wednesday so
be listening for those thank you so much
conan i appreciate that